The global competency lab is a region
with 12 countries that have just one
thing in common and that's that they all
hate each other.
For decades,
most of these countries were a big part
of a federation called Yugoslavia,
which had a socialist system very
similar to that of the Soviet Union.
After the fall of communism,
the Yugoslavian estate broke apart and
all the regions separated from each
other in the most violent way possible,
either about my age or slightly older
you might remember the terrible bulk and
was a showcase of the worst part of the
human condition.
As all of this happens just a few
kilometers away from Italy and from
Greece,
so while the rest of Europe enjoyed a
comfortable and peaceful existence,
this region's inhabitants were killing
each other.
Since then,
the Balkans in one of Europe's poorest
regions.
Some people call it the Bermuda triangle
of economics because when someone
invests that money mysteriously
disappears.
Probably new country like Albania is a
bit like traveling 50 years in the past.
Other countries like Serbia or growing
fairly fast lately,
but there are still miles away from
being able to join the European Union.
Greece,
which is the best boy in the classroom,
is bankrupt and has an unemployment rate
of 21 percent and otherwise this doesn't
look like a good country for doing
business.
Right?
Well,
give you A.
China thinks it is.
Yes.
China is putting billions of pounds
worth of investment into Greece and
other Balkan countries to create a new
silk road from the Mediterranean into
the heart.
The European Union,
we aren't talking about almost
$20,000,000,000.
This is the same cost as hosting the
Olympic Games and it's all in a region
where nobody else seems to invest a
penny.
China is bought harbor and is now
building brand new railroads that will
connect to the Balkans with Budapest in
Hungary and that might ended up in
Germany,
but not only that,
the Chinese government is paving the way
for private investments.
Can you imagine Chinese factories on the
outskirts of Belgrade and Alley Express
logistics center in the middle of
Athens?
Bob,
this might be a reality sooner than you
might have
facts
for better understanding.
If we look at it relative to that
population,
China is showing a bigger interest in
Greece,
Australia than it is in Germany,
so now the question is why is China so
interested in the Balkans?
Isn't this a poor,
corrupt,
and business unfriendly region?
What is China trying to achieve here?
Well,
today we are going to answer all of
these questions,
but as usual before we do a second look
back at the history tree for sale in the
year 2010,
Greece started that budget cuts.
The whole country was bankrupt and the
European Union agreed to bail them out
with money from it's wealthiest members.
Boss can exchange.
The Greek government was supposed to
control that spending.
Since then,
Greece has gone through all kinds of
political and financial crisis.
Unemployment Sims,
he doesn't stop growing.
It's now at more than 20 percent since
poverty is on the rise too,
for a better understanding.
Greek public desk is almost twice that
of their entire gross domestic product,
and on top of all of this grease seems
to be allergic to business,
ev,
rampant corruption,
red tape,
and all kinds of laws that have created
a country with almost no major
companies.
Brussels demands is that the government
of Alexis Tsipras make reforms and sell
the state owned companies,
but there was a big problem here being
in the situation that they were.
Nobody wanted to buy the Greek
governments property,
so they simply had to drop their prices
to rock bottom.
In other words,
Greece was and still is in a desperate
situation now,
guests,
you can smell desperation from miles and
miles away.
Yup.
That would be China.
China's costco acquires 51 percent stake
in pirates passport.
When this deal,
China was killing two birds with one
stone.
On the one hand,
it's one of their companies was buying
one of the main ports in the
Mediterranean seat on the other.
The government of Xi Jinping with his
commitments to investing at 3 billion
more dollars in the country was buying
it from this angle ally in sight,
the EU and.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
I know what you'll now thinking.
The Greek presidents,
Alexis suppressed the European left
Rockstar,
the man who would never sell his
principles to an evil rich guy.
No matter how much money was put on the
table.
Yeah,
yeah.
We need that.
Breeze blocks used criticism at UN of
China's human rights record.
Greece has vetoed a European Union
condemnation of China's human rights
record at the UN infuriating diplomats
and rights organizations.
You said the move undermine that used
position as a defender of human,
right?
Just a minute,
because this is not only about politics
here.
Let's take a look at it from an economic
perspective.
Now,
a Chinese company controls one of the
biggest ports in Europe.
This means Chinese businesses will find
it easier than ever to reload their
products into one of the wealthiest
markets on the planet.
Europe,
but still has a little problem here from
the Pi report.
Berlin,
we have more than 2000,
300 kilometers of distance on the way.
We have poor countries with poor roads
and poor railways,
but hold on just a second day because
China has already thought of this.
Do you remember the one belt?
One road projects.
This is brands.
New Silk Road,
Xi Jinping wants to create.
This is a network of infrastructure that
is meant to connect the entire wells and
in Europe the silkroad will go through
the Balkans.
Oh,
great.
Budapest railway construction starts at
the same time.
Chinese consulting companies are working
to renovate railroads between Greece and
Macedonia.
The goal is to be able to have one
shipment,
Madigan pirates and crossing the whole
Balkan peninsula at a hundred and 60
kilometers an hour,
and all of this is cheaper to build here
than intercity.
I mean,
think about it.
The vulcans have cheap land,
cheap salaries and their governments are
welcoming this Chinese money with open
arms.
As we said at the beginning,
the Balkans still feel a bit like the
aftermath of the wars from the 19th.
Let me see sooner like Bill Craig,
you can still see the ruins from the
NATO bombings in 1999.
A country like Montenegro doesn't even
have a railroad that connects it with
Bosnia or Croatia despite sharing a
border.
Don't forget that except for Greece and
Coratia,
none of these countries are you members.
This means that they hardly get any
Brussels money to rebuild,
so these Chinese loans,
$70 from heaven speak about this with
European countries.
They say,
why China?
Because they have the money to be
honest.
Zerana,
Z,
Milosevic,
Serbian minister of transportation,
but hold on just a second here because
this is not the end of the story.
What if China wants to go even further?
Trainees,
factories in Europe,
we'll know it.
China started grabbing thanks to the
foreign companies that set up in these
special economic science,
but the truth is the real appeal of
China during the nineties was the lower
wages,
however things they've now changed.
Take a look at this chart today.
The average salary in a city like
Shanghai is almost the same as that in
Greece and almost double that of the
Saudi and salary.
This means for a Chinese company,
Sedia is something close to what Shen
Zen used to be for an American.
There's also the fact that said the
uneducation is relatively good and
they're close to Germany in summary,
cheap labor,
well educated population,
and it's close to one of the world's
most appealing markets.
This is an unexplored paradise.
China's Habib signs agreement to buy
serving steel plant.
Of course,
this news is from 2016 and we still
don't have that many examples,
but that aren't enough cases to show a
clear trends.
Chinese companies want to start
manufacturing things in Europe and the
Balkans.
Other perfect place to do that.
Most specifically.
Then looking at Sandia,
this explains why this year,
Xi Jinping himself paid a visit to
Belgrade or why Huawei has already
invested at a fortune to improved
telecommunications in the country.
Last year,
that's 2017.
The Bank of China opens their first
Serbian officers.
So in a way we could say that the
relationship between these two countries
where it really couldn't be any better
right now,
but I can probably guess what you're
thinking right now.
I mean very rarely a visual politic.
Do we tell you that corruption is a
friend of foreign investments and when
it comes to corruption,
sedia certainly starts to look less like
a paradise,
but make no mistake.
Chinese companies are experts in dealing
with this.
In fact,
Chinese businessmen are quite
comfortable in hostile environments.
They have demonstrated this when they
built those textile factories in
Ethiopia,
and let's be honest here,
China itself isn't exactly a haven of
transparency and democracy either.
Meanwhile,
as soon as investment came to the
Balkans,
the regions fondness for Europe,
it started going down in 2012.
Seventy percent of Serbs wanted to join
the European Union.
Some people were even willing to change
that alphabet.
To do that.
As you probably know,
Serbian is a Slavic language and it's
written in cyrillic characters.
Some intellectuals wanted to change it
to a Latin alphabet is the same way you
Croatians dips,
but now,
well,
this love of Europe,
it's dropped to 35 percent at the end of
the day with money flowing into China.
Well,
he really wants Brussels funding.
In past presidential elections,
none of the main candidates talked about
joining the European Union.
Nevertheless,
nobody in Brussels seemed to be too
worried about that.
You said only China has been capable of
finding business opportunities in this
part of the world.
The rest of Europe still sees this as a
political and economic desert.
The same happens in many parts of
Africa.
When nobody dead to invest,
all of a sudden Beijing money came in
and now some of these countries are
growing like this note.
So the question is now where we see an
awakening in the Balkans is the same
way.
We've seen it in some African countries
and he could grease Saudi and perhaps
even Bosnia.
They come a brand new industrial cluster
for Chinese companies.
Well,
let us know what you think in the
comments section below and meanwhile,
if you want to know more about why
Australia,
China,
these do click on this video and also
don't forget to visit the reconsider
media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this
episode.
Good on mine.
Also,
don't forget brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
as always,
thank you for watching and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my left voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.